it's too cold to change out here
dang i'm late for mom's rally
[Music]
subway card check you got the house key
yeah i got it
[Music]
come on we're gonna be late
hey dude i am so filling your suit with
snow
are you still wearing your suit yeah you
know just in case
it's gonna be fine
see this is my favorite part of living
in harlem
pop-up street fair best food in the city
awesome music
man this would be great for the last
beat i was working on
i should get back into mixing yeah it's
been a while
what do you think about rio morales you
gonna vote for her
it's still hard to think of mom as a
politician she's been a teacher my whole
life
similar skill sets right growling people
educating them
making sure they don't throw things at
each other
hi i'm brian horton creative director at
insomniac games
we're excited to show you this first
look at game play from marvel spider-man
miles morales
our story picks up one year after the
events of the first game
and we find miles new home harlem is in
danger
trouble brews while mile's mom rio
morales leads an election rally
a war between the devious energy
corporation roxanne and the underground
a high-tech criminal army led by the
tinkerer starts to break out
in this gameplay sequence captured on
playstation 5 hardware
the underground attacks roxanne sending
the rally into chaos in a fight that
spills onto the brake weight bridge
where the underground tries to steal
roxanne's experimental energy source new
form
let's take a look
let's not shoot each other all right
[Music]
we're after the new form ignore
everything else
[Music]
get rid of him then grab as much as you
can carry
keep him busy
i have to stop this
uh
people are trapped over there i have to
push past these
where guys he
no
no no no no no
[Music]
don't worry i got you
i've got an idea
i need something they can cross
i can stop this
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new spider-man ps5
miles morales trailer video
hopefully if you tried to pre-order a
playstation 5 yesterday you were
successful it was a bit of a nightmare
but i will be giving away copies of the
game once they actually release it it'll
be coming out pretty soon all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave your favorite spider-man game
on the video but in this trailer they
explain everything about what's going on
with the villains of the game they've
already explained where this game fits
in the timeline
and how it's related to spider-man ps4
and what the actual
sequel the spider-man ps5 will wind up
being
so just to be clear even though this is
the very first spider-man ps5 game that
they're releasing it's actually
built on the technology from spider-man
ps4
but it's just sort of like uprezzed for
hdr and ps5 hardware
it's not meant to be the full-blown
direct sequel to spider-man ps4 it's
more of a sidequel like a side adventure
with miles morales so peter parker is
still okay he hasn't died or anything
like that
there will be a true spider-man ps5
sequel to spider-man ps4 we don't know
when that's going to be released
sometime in the next couple of years but
they're working on that right now
they did remaster spider-man ps4 for the
ps5 and they'll include a free copy of
that
on the miles morales game so if you buy
that you get the free
upgraded version of spider-man ps4 but
as you can see it's been at least
six months since the end of spider-man
ps4 he's moved to harlem you see all the
christmas paraphernalia all over the
place the christmas trees
you see the snow in the air so obviously
this is at the end of the year around
christmas time
genki seems like a much bigger character
during this game than he was during the
spider-man into the spider-verse movie
but i think a lot of his scenes were
actually cut from spider-man into the
spider-verse so he might be a bigger
character during the sequel
clearly he's been spider-man for a while
now he's got the black suit and genki
has learned his secret identity because
he jokes about him wearing his suit
underneath his clothes to his mother's
rally like oh i'm just wearing it just
in case
you notice the spider-man peter parker
mural on the building in the background
as they start to walk into the street
fair you see a bunch of ads for the
in-universe soda brand from spider-man
ps4 the swilco
soda you notice that his mom is running
on an anti-roxanne campaign so they're
kind of positioning roxanne as sort of
the evil corporate overlords like you
would think of ozcorp during the regular
spider-man ps4 game
they're pretty evil company in the
comics but not quite as infamous as
companies like ozcorp and they're not
quite as
big just in terms of capitalization as
like stark industries or other really
big marvel companies
the other funny thing about this too is
that i actually used to live near this
area in harlem where this game is taking
place
back in the late 2000s when i was still
living in new york city
my entire apartment was small enough to
fit inside what looks like miles morales
bedroom
as they walk through the street fair
though you notice more booths for the
feast shelter from the spider-man ps4 so
it seems like they'll just continue to
be part of the story heading into
spider-man ps5
then the devs sort of set up the
scenario here and who the villains on
both sides are so they're sort of
positioning the tinker and his
underground group
of vigilantes as villains but also
roxanne are the villains and miles
morales is caught in the middle
trying to minimize collateral damage if
you're not a big comic book reader the
ultimate version of the tinkerer
actually used to be a roxon
employee so that's probably why the
tinker is going after roxon in this game
the fact that they're using the purple
energy to distinguish the tinkers men
from the rocks and men also seems like a
bit of an easter egg for spider-man
homecoming in that version of the tinker
in the vulture who are repurposing the
chatauri tech with purple energy
into weapons for the black market they
try to steal roxanne's energy source
which the tinker probably
worked on at some point if they're a
former roxanne employee you can kind of
see the scenario there where he probably
got fired from roxane and that's why he
hates them so much
miles morales gives him the ultimate
clap back with his venom ability and you
actually get a good look at how his
combos stack together in combat the
soundtrack is pretty
cool too i've never seen such continuous
use
of venom in any kind of miles morales
fight scene so i'm interested to see how
they implement this during spider-man
into the spider-verse 2.
the venom sting ability in that is blue
so it just looks a little bit different
it seems like most of his fight scenes
during spider-man into the spider-verse
2 will feel a little bit more like this
more combo moves more advanced more
creative use of venom stings
he tries to web up the pieces of the
bridge as it starts collapsing which
feels like another easter egg and a wink
at the fairy save from spider-man
homecoming it's the same outcome
the webbing is super strong but it only
slows the inevitable collapse just long
enough for him to save those people
but what'll happen is when we get a
little bit closer to the game coming out
i'll start doing some giveaways for
copies of the actual game so as long as
you have alerts enabled for my channel
you should see all those videos when i
post them i'll just do those in my
marvel videos
and good luck to all of you who are
still trying to score a playstation 5
i've already done a bunch of videos
about spider-man into the spider-verse
2. you can click here for the teaser
trailer for that
and you can click here for the brand new
trailer for the mandalorian season 2
new episodes starting in a couple weeks
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay
safe i'll see you guys tonight